we told you yesterday that governors in
texas and florida are giving joe biden a
taste of his own medicine
greg abbott texas
bussing and flying illegal immigrants in
his state straight to washington d.c
and ron desantis is dumping them in
biden's home state of delaware
press secretary jensachi was asked about
the drop-offs today watch
when they get here are you guys going to
help them find a place to stay and
something for them to do well i'm not
aware of what authority the governor
would be doing that under i think it's
pretty clear this is a publicity stunt
his own
office admits that a migrant would need
to voluntarily be transported and he
can't compel them to because again
enforcement of our country's immigration
laws lies with the federal government
not a state washington d.c well listen i
don't know but i know that the governor
of texas or any state does not have the
legal authority to compel anyone to get
on a bus
my next guest knows all about being a
press secretary and possibly
a future governor sarah huckabee sanders
joins me now with her take all right
sarah huckabee sanders it's good to have
you back here good to see you it's good
to be with you good to see you too it is
kind of sad though that that these
illegal immigrants are being used as
political pawns just to embarrass joe
biden into actually doing
his job do you
agree well joe biden's doing a pretty
good job embarrassing himself he sent a
message very clearly on day one of his
administration that the border was open
to the world
he has never once taken action to secure
our border or to stop people from coming
in under president trump we had a secure
border we were working whether it was
through the remain in mexico policy
things like title 42 or the physical
wall itself our border was far more
secure
since biden has come in he has allowed a
national security a health and
humanitarian crisis to take place at the
border allowing the drugs and cartel
violence to flood in across our southern
border and i'm thankful that governors
are stepping up because that's what it's
going to take because we cannot count on
the federal government under biden's
leadership to actually do something
they've created this problem there's no
doubt that they're going to only
continue to allow it to get worse and so
i'm glad that strong conservative
governors are stepping up and taking
actual steps to do something about it
because we know that it's not going to
happen at the hands of the biden
administration that is for sure and i
know people in your state very concerned
about corruption we're concerned about
corruption here
and there's a lot of corruption in
washington as you observed while you
were there working very hard so aoc
actually called out nancy pelosi today
because you know nancy makes a mint
trading stocks excuse me her husband
does
and she basically said this is really
corrupt whether it is or it just looks
like it listen
there is a very very very direct
connection between us holding ourselves
to a higher standard holding and having
that include our families and uh you
know and there there are many different
proposals here but you know whether it's
spouses whether it's children whether
it's senior uh staff members who are
also in the room when it comes to
uh when it comes to writing down the
actual lines we have to be able to
assure
the american people that
it's not happening here and that they
don't have to worry about if they're
competing with their member of
congress's stock portfolio in order to
be heard
now that was a direct shot at the
speaker of the house your reaction
look i'm always pretty suspect of
anything coming from aoc but one thing
uh that i might say i slightly agree is
that members of congress should never be
enriching themselves when they're there
to serve the public and so i i certainly
hope that we can hold people accountable
i don't know that i would count on her
to be the person to lead that charge
yeah i don't i wouldn't put her in
charge of anything but at least she said
the right thing there all right sarah
huckabee sanders thanks so much for
joining us
you bet thanks jesse hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else